something more powerful than any of us
in Avengers age of Ultron the Avengers
have to deal with the issue of the
global entity it's a different playing
field we're dealing with these
situations on a kind of global level as
much as it could be it's a much bigger
film than the first Avengers
it's just visually where we're going in
Italy it's incredibly cold and rainy and
foggy and we love it
New York's home to the Avengers Tower
which is massive
very enthusiastic fan they're very
welcoming letting us take over their
streets for a few days
today the Avengers finds himself at
Dover Castle continuing the world tour
we want to look at the Avengers see the
effect they have on the whole world for
them to come to places like Johannesburg
and take with them the inevitable
trouble that follows them how that
affects their perception of each other
and the world perception
want to protect the world but you don't
want it to change
we've gone too far more locations that
we have ever before and I kind of
covered more ground and so aesthetically
everything has just been dialed up
Avengers time to work for a living
you
hey youtubers is Charlie so everybody
freaked out a little bit yesterday when
joss whedon said there's no post credit
scene in Avengers age of Ultron so I
want to explain what he meant when he
said that and talked about my top 10
Marvel post-credit scenes just from the
Marvel Cinematic Universe
what Joss Whedon said is is that there
is no after the credits scene but there
are scenes at the end of the movie that
will set up the next phase 3 movies most
notably Captain America Civil War that's
a really important one for next year
because it's almost an Avengers film by
itself there's Thor 3 Ragnarok which is
kind of like Thor's version of Winter
Soldier and then there's ant-man
although I'm not expecting to see a
whole lot of ant-man stuff right now
it's like Marvel's stepchild that's kind
of sitting in the corner don't worry
I'll do more ant-man videos after age of
Ultron comes out you also have to
remember that they could always change
their mind sometimes what they'll do is
is they won't put post-credit scenes on
like critics screenings or like the very
first overseas screenings and then
they'll add them later once the movie is
out like everywhere that's kind of what
happened when guardians of the galaxy
came out like most of the critics that
went to see it were like there's no post
credit scene but Marvel and Disney had
just omitted it from all those early
screenings they didn't add it until it
was in wide release so worst case
scenario all those end credits scenes
just happened before the end credits we
can get into like post credits spoilers
and stuff like that when the movie comes
out so it's gonna be a lot of fun so top
10 Marvel post credits scenes starting
with number 10 Science Bros counselling
at the end of Iron Man 3 the movie
itself was kind of an outlier in terms
of Avengers films just because it came
after the first Avengers film so
everyone was expecting this really big
grand spectacle and it ended up being
this deep dive into Tony Stark but the
science bros at the end of the film I
feel like was a perfect addition it was
much more personal Marvel film in
general and science Bros is just a much
more personal thing just a funny twist
on the idea of banner being a doctor and
the two of them being in close contact
like being friends while the timeline of
all these movies is going along like in
the background like they have each other
on speed dial or something Mark Ruffalo
is actually said in interviews that
there's a whole bunch of science bros in
age of Ultron so if you guys really like
the moments with those two characters
together you're really gonna have some
fun monster number 9 Thor's hammer at
the end of Iron Man 2 one of the Messier
Marvel films in terms of like plotting
structure just overall cohesion but
Thor's hammer at the end was a big
teaser just because it was before the
first Avengers film
so they were just like setting up the
next big character franchise I think of
all the Avengers characters that they've
done solo films for Hulk and Thor have
been really hard cells for Marvel they
just never been quite as popular as Iron
Man or Captain America you have to
remember that Captain America hadn't
come out yet so this was like the next
big Avenger so this was a huge deal and
it was a really funny Coulson moment and
everyone's wondering when he's gonna
show up in the movies again I'll talk
about that a little bit more during
agents of shield when we get closer to
age of Ultron onto number 8 Howard the
Duck at the end of guardians this is
just one of those pure fun moments
because we got Cosmo the dog we got a
broken Adam warlock cocoon and we have
Howard the Duck who a lot of people have
forgotten was a Marvel character so it's
just James Gunn having a lot of fun like
this isn't meant to mean anything it's
just supposed to be funny enjoy it
originally this was supposed to be Stan
Lee in the case but they ended up
changing at the last minute Stan Lee
mint condition fresh in his packaging
also number 7 another guardians moment
dancing baby Groot another just pure fun
moment on the part of James Gunn but
this is actually more relevant to the
plotline Groot will come back although
the funny thing is is that James Gunn
teased that it might be a different
group like this might be son of grewed
in the comics that's not the way it
works GRU could just regenerate himself
onto number 6 shawarma at the end of the
first Avengers film this is like the
scene I think Joss Whedon was talking
about when he said that he's not going
to do another post-credit scene in age
of Ultron something he said at Comic Con
last year I think when one of the actors
like Robert Downey jr. or Chris Evans or
someone asked him hey Joss how are we
gonna beat you know that that fun scene
from the last film that swarm a scene
and Joss Whedon said sometimes the only
way to win is to not play the game that
kind of makes me think of wargames with
Matthew Broderick
but really what Joss Whedon men is is it
like they're just not gonna try and keep
topping themselves because it can't be
done like a lot of the magic of this
shawarma scene is that it was so
unexpected and now that everyone's
expecting that from Marvel it's just you
don't get the same payoff moving on to
number 5 the collectors warehouse at the
end of Thor the dark world this is
actually really important because one it
continues setting up the idea of the
infinity gems or Infinity stones if you
go by the movie saying the scene is also
the first time we see Adam warlocks
cocoon which is like you know huge
character from the Marvel Canon very
closely tied with Thanos so it's like if
they're gonna do the Annis Infinity
Gauntlet it also helps if Adam
Morlock exist in this universe just
because he's heavily featured in stories
with the Infinity Gauntlet I know a lot
of people are wondering about Phase
three
Adam warlock in the soul gem because in
the comics Adam warlock is tied directly
to the soul gem and it kind of looks
like this is the soul gem in visions
forehead here as opposed to the solar
gem that he has in the comics so the
movies might be changing that we don't
know yet just just keep a tab open and
Chrome I'll have to wait till the movie
comes out to find out for sure I know a
lot of people are wondering why the
movies change the infinity gems like why
Twilight we have the aether we have the
tesseract like infinity gems in
different forms I think it's really just
to make it more visually interesting and
I think initially whenever Marvel was
first doing this Thanos was an idea in
their head fan of Infinity Gauntlet but
if any of the films along the way ended
up being unsuccessful I think Marvel
wanted like a side plan obviously it did
pay off so now they're like okay these
are all Infinity stones here we go on to
number four Quicksilver and Scarlet
Witch at the end of Winter Soldier
nothing is more horrifying than a
miracle that was one of the greatest
lines ever regardless of how awesome
Baron von Strucker ends up being what
he's doing is very important and I know
there's some controversy as to whether a
Quicksilver and Scarlet Witch are going
to be called Inhumans or if they're
gonna be called something else because
their powers derive from the mind gem
even if Quicksilver and Scarlet Witch
aren't Inhumans I do believe that the
movie will invoke the idea of Inhumans
console number three Nick Fury dr.
Selvig and Loki look at the tesseract at
the end of the first Thor film this is
really big because it was a teaser for
Avengers which was still a long way off
we saw that Captain America coming and
think about how many films the tesseract
was actually featured in and it
confirmed that Loki was not dead
although although he looked like he'd
been to hell and back and when I say
hell I mean Thanos was domain and
sanctuary on to number two Nick Fury
explains The Avengers initiative at the
end of the first Iron Man film this was
the beginning of it all and Jon Favreau
tells a really funny story about how he
got samuel l.jackson to do the cameo and
how secretive they were about it he said
he had a black limo like literally drive
from the street into the soundstage to
try and keep it a secret but people
still found out they were like oh hey
it's Nick Fury they're teasing Avengers
this was in 2008 so if you think like
leaks from the set like people taking
pictures spoilers from the set or bad
now think about how hard people work to
find this out back in 2008
and at the time they had no idea what
Samuel Jackson was gonna mean inside the
Marvel Cinematic Universe they knew he
was playing Nick Fury but like his role
in all the other films hadn't really
been determined yet it was just meant to
be like this fun went off thing for the
fans of course all the other films ended
up being hugely successful so that they
leave Nick Fury in a much bigger way as
they went along with Phil Coulson and
finally my number one Marvel
post-credits scene
Thanos at the end of the first Avengers
film this put the universe in Marvel
Cinematic Universe even if you haven't
read any of the Infinity Gauntlet
storylines or any stories with a nose in
it you know that this is a huge deal he
is the biggest big bad of the Marvel
Universe as of right now there's a lot
of rumors as to like which other films
he's gonna appear in before infinity war
I would expect him to at least appear in
guardians of the galaxy because that's
the only space-based franchise that we
have right now inside the Marvel
Cinematic Universe I'm not gonna hold my
breath for age of Ultron but it's also
possible he could have like a brief
cameo in it what I'm expecting from him
is that Josh Brolin's performance his
mocap performance will evolve as the
film's developed just because technology
will get a little bit better and we'll
have more time with him just roll I'll
have more time to spend with the
character when he appeared in guardians
of the galaxy it was really just a
single day with a bunch of mocap dots on
his face he wasn't even onscreen for
that long so the next time he appears
it'll probably in a much bigger way so
he did my big question for you guys what
is your favorite Marvel post-credit
scene and actually which one do you
think is the worst I would say you know
maybe Incredible Hulk just because it
was kind of a throwaway line like the
Marvel Cinematic Universe had really
come together at that point yet in
related news this is actually really big
week because daredevil is dropping all
13 episodes on Friday I'm gonna do as
many Vince as possible probably like one
video for every two episodes of
daredevil so be sure to subscribe to get
everything
HBO is also dropping Game of Thrones
this Sunday and I always do a bunch of
videos for that so if you guys haven't
started watching Game of Thrones you can
get HBO now for $15 a month and stream
everything for free for 30 days like
they have a 30 day trial if you sign up
right now so lots of daredevil coming
and lots of Game of Thrones and I will
be doing my weekly Game of Thrones
giveaways just to get you guys psyched
up for daredevil you can click here for
my non-spoilery review of the first two
episodes and you can click here for some
big updates on Avengers 3 thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight
you